shelby's with us in Texas hi Shelby
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up has not yes I think over $400,000 of
debt and she has no plans to do anything
about it and it's all kinds of debt the
way it's affecting me is that her
parents are calling me they called my
husband they called his parents and
nothing I say is getting her to change
anything I don't know what power what if
anything I could do to get her creditors
to stop calling us well the first thing
I would do is ask them nicely then just
say I have nothing to do with this debt
this is not my debt and the fact that
you're calling me on this debt is
illegal based on federal law the Federal
Fair Debt Collection Practices Act says
they're violating the Privacy Act a
collector is not allowed to call and
divulge to a third party you the private
information about someone else and the
fact that they have let you know that
they're a bill collector on your mother
means they have violated federal law and
so tell them what you're going to do is
you're going to start recording their
calls and give the recording to your
mother so that she can sue them okay
that'll help okay
that's that's the that's the nicest one
that's the nicest way of doing the
problem is when you're dealing with
collectors most the time you're not
dealing with intelligent life you're
having a conversation with a scum burger
who you can tell is lying if their mouth
is moving I'm not having a conversation
with these people I'm just simply going
to tell them what is going to happen if
you call here again
one of two things is going to happen at
my choice thing number one is I'm going
to record the conversation so that my
other can use it to sue you or if you
call here again I'm going to use a
sports
airhorn and see if I can definite
so that your ears don't work again and
then you'll get the idea to never call
here again because this is an obscene
phone call okay either one of those
options are fun and you might as well
have some fun because these people
listen you can't fix your momma she's
$400,000 in debt all you can do is make
these people wish they never called you
again that's your best shot you can pray
for your mom if your mom wants your help
you can help her but you do not owe this
money you do not have unintelligent
conversations with stupid people do not
bother this is not a conversation this
is some what these people try this crap
because ignorant people will pay their
mother's bills and you're not ignorant
you're not going to commit to pay
anything any of this you're not gonna
give them a dime they violated federal
law and they're either gonna get
recorded and sued or get a sports
airhorn your choice and we can set you
up for problems here because these
people are scum and they're calling
everybody in that town and you know why
they keep calling you because they're
getting a reaction out of you and if
they know if they get a reaction out of
you they may end up getting money out of
you so you need to change the reaction
that you're giving them to an unpleasant
reaction and you can be as mean or nasty
on the phone as you want to be but it's
you doing all the talking and then you
hanging up and by the way I know you're
in the south and hanging up is not a
cause for you to lose your salvation and
go to help you can't hang up on people
who should not have called your house we
were taught growing up that if you hung
up the phone on someone that was like
worse than smacking their sister or
something and it's just not okay just to
hang up the phone it's a simple
disconnect of an electronic connection
everything's okay no one dies from it
everything's okay and we really don't
care if their feelings are hurt because
these people are psychopaths they don't
really have feelings their credit card
collectors so just you know just move on
kiddo and you just have to you have to
treat them like the scum that they are
and there's an
way around him Oh Dave Ramsey called
credit card collector scum and I'm a
credit card collector I don't like that
you know what I don't care if you don't
want be scum don't be a credit card
collector because if your credit card
collector you're scum these things are
tied together